cd projekt red may be hiring a group of
community modders to help with cyberpunk
2077 we got our very first look at
welcome to raccoon city today and
tomorrow we're getting a chance to check
out the dead space remake halo the
master chief collection is also ramping
up a seasoning flight that's full of
quality of life updates and even a brand
new map for halo 3. i'm persia and this
is your gamespot news update for august
30th
cd projekt red could be bringing members
of cyberpunk 2077's modding community on
board to work on back in cyberpunk 2077
projects and modding support the news
spread on twitter after a screenshot of
the announcement from the team's discord
was shared online but we've yet to hear
any official word from cd projekt red at
this time the group of modders will be
contracted under their own company
yigsoft which has also created wolven
kit an open source mod editor for cd
projekt red games including the witcher
3 and it's said to be the reason why
mods even exist for cyberpunk 2077.
this morning we got our very first look
at the cast of welcome to raccoon city
which is the upcoming resident evil film
the three images revealed the new actors
for the live-action movie kiosk delario
as claire redfield evan jogia as leon
kennedy tom hopper as albert wesker
nathan dales as brad vickers hannah john
common as jill valentine and robbie
amell as chris redfield the images also
revealed marina mazepa who will be
playing lisa trevor this will be the
character's first time appearing on the
big screen welcome to raccoon city will
serve as an origin story to the original
resident evil games and focus on
resident evil and resident evil 2. the
movie is being directed by johannes
roberts who previously directed the
stranger's prey at night and 47 meters
down in an interview with ign roberts
said his film will deviate from the
prior resident evil movie starring milo
jovovich because it will focus on more
horror rather than being an action film
when asked about the casting robert said
his focus was not to have actors feel
like a cosplay of the characters and
instead focus on how each of the main
characters carries a huge importance to
the narrative welcome to raccoon city
comes to theaters on november 24th
ea is going to reveal some more details
on motive studios new dead space remake
as a part of a live stream event that
they announced for motive studios twitch
channel in a note to media ea said the
broadcast will show off an early
development build of the new dead space
game senior producer philip ducharme and
creative director roman campos oriola
will appear on the stream to discuss
their vision for the game along with
special guests from the dead space
community council a team of fans who
have been consulting with ea it's
important to note that the build that
will be shown in the live stream is an
early prototype of the game and not
final in any capacity it is meant to
illustrate motives vision of dead space
in motion for the community the new dead
space is not a reboot or a remaster it
is a remake of the first game where
everything has been rebuilt from the
ground up running on the frostbite
engine ea says the new remake will be
respectful of the original dead space
isn't expected to release until the end
of 2022 at the soonest for links and
specific times visit gamespot.com and
check out our viewing guide
while custom games have been available
to halo mcc players for quite a while
one of the system's tie-in features file
sharing has been missing for pc players
file sharing which as its name suggests
lets the player download and share
custom maps game modes and even in-game
screenshots with each other and has been
a mainstay on the franchise's console
releases according to a forum post file
sharing on pc will arrive with
everything players should expect and
trust levels which can be set for other
players halo mcc's custom games browser
on the other hand will also be getting
its own suite of improvements as of
right now it's pretty bare bones but the
upcoming season 8 flight will not only
cover halo reach but also halo combat
evolved and halo 3.
this version of the browser will also
come with numerous quality of life
improvements including better search
functions filters and changes to sub
menus when the season 8 flight for halo
the master chief collection launches
this week players will also get to play
a brand new map for halo 3. the map
titled icebox is a remake of the halo 2
map turf
a list of all of the other changes are
on our website right now if you want to
head on over and take a look at
everything that's heading your way
during this season 8 flight
all right everyone be sure to leave a
like and subscribe so you don't miss any
of our news updates and we're streaming
the dead space stream tomorrow morning
right here on our youtube channel so
make sure you stop by for that too thank
you so much for watching and we'll see
you next time
you